قال نائب رئيس مجلس الاندلس
ان الضغط على النفط الروسيه سيؤدي الى
قفزه لا يمكن تخيلها في الاسعار العالميه
حسب وصفه
على تليجرام الى ان الغربه سي يتجمد هذا
الشتاء نتيجه دخوله في معركه غير متكافئه
مع الدب الروسي وثلوج الشتاء القاهره
تخزين المشروبات الكحوليه والارضيه واجهزه
التدفئه
هذا وقالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كارين جون بيار ان الحد الاقصى الذي تم
فرضه على سعر النفط الروسي لا يزال
المحفزه لروسيا لتستمر بتصدير نفضها
واضافت ان امتنا ستكون له تداعيات عليها
وبخلاف ذلك سيكون هناك
اقصى على سعر النفط الروسي هو اجراء غير
مسبوق ويظهر الوحده التي تتمتع بها
الولايات المتحده والحلفاء والشركاء
الدوليه
روسيا من النفط خلال فتره الحرب
لا اعتقد انه سيكون له تاثير كبير في
اسعار النفط العالميه بل سينحصل تاثيره في
اسعار النفط الروسيه كما تعلمون تبيعوا
روسيا النفط في الاسهم باليورو ونعلم ان
سعر البرميل الذي باعته روسيا عبر موانئها
خلال الاسبوع الماضي لم يتجاوز 60 دولارا
للبرميل بالنسبه الروسي متوسط التكليفه
وسعره اقل من خام برنت وارخص بكثير حتى
اذا وضعته في اسيا والسقف الذي حددناه حدا
للعائدات التي يمكن جنينها من بيع ان يفتح
خلال هذه المده من الحرب